bro uh no now see now
now i'm thinking you've seen that tick
tock where it's like oh humans
have been the way we've been for the
last 2000 or 200 000 years or whatever
but only like five percent of our
existence has recorded history okay
does that mean there's a squirter like
way back then
yeah like you think when they're like
figuring out fire and stuff like
like the guy who made fire was like and
then
finally and then some girl score yeah
she put it out and she scored it
i was like
and everyone's like yeah
and the guy who made it solid come on
[Music]
everyone's like shut up
and then they're like like you know
they're like finding their currency like
little wood chips yeah
yeah little pieces or whatever
no they're just throwing berries yeah
yeah yeah
the guy's like guys just sitting there
freezing
the rest of the group wakes up every
morning gotta find berries
[Music]
yeah that image of this dude making
fires like
huh
[Laughter]
this caveman rage yeah yeah
that's i think that's actually was was
drawn in hieroglyphics
yeah not hieroglyphics but you know
caveman drawing drawings on the side
yeah that's like fire caribou squirt
squirt yeah
and then just a really angry dude yeah
and we've been
we've been interpreting it as like a
storm or something yeah the last 100
years yeah
like a squirter in like the ming dynasty
all right
um here's something i want to go over
with you like right away
okay okay you're all right so i guess
yeah i just think this is
like i'm in trouble yeah we need to talk
dude we need to talk about something
right
away on air we gotta talk okay
this is this is so funny so
okay so paige she's in paige
paige halsey she's an anchor slash
reporter at kmov in
in uh st louis right okay
they i guess they staged this this like
teens room to show parents like where a
team could be hiding drugs yeah
and so our tweet says looks like a
normal teen's bedroom right
think again coming up on kmov we'll show
you what parents
should be looking for so they can
identify signs of drug use yeah i was
shocked at what i found in this room
so it's supposed to be can you pull it
up
can you pull up could you pull up real
fast
so this is the room right here right
classic teen's bedroom
huh yeah right yeah but if you look
closer
yeah that mile 420 sign i have that in
my this
someone someone zoomed in and said bro
is that a three hole punch on the bed
dog and it is that is what's up
to simulate a teen's bedroom right now
what teenager
is using paper even knows that paper
exists yeah
none no this this bedroom should be
they kind of got that right with like a
drape on the wall
um yeah but the tie-dye no the maybe not
the tie-dye
it should be something you know more uh
you know trippy yeah or k-poppy or
something
something you know what it should be is
an unmade bed
clothes all over the floor 20
carts littered all over it yeah and then
um
possibly one of their friends passed out
on xanax in the bed yeah exactly yeah
and then the other
teen like with her like feet in the air
or his yeah on their stomach watching
tick tock
yeah or streaming or something like that
yeah yeah it needs to be a little bit
more euphoria
you know bro this is a little bit too
this is like
college freshman at bm or byu
yeah in 1998 exactly
bro uh i saw one of the replies to this
was
uh you know like criticizing the room
like
whatever and then that reporter
responded was like i was surprised to
find that
teens will use tampon containers to hide
marijuana
i'm like dude you definitely did not
know anyone that smoked weed in high
school yeah
people use all kinds of [ __ ] to hide
with oh yeah oh yeah
people putting it in a bag and an orange
peel oh yeah like
yeah or a shampoo bottle i think all of
them before submerging
shampoo oh yeah yeah yeah so the smell
doesn't
yeah yeah i think the funniest thing
about this whole report is it
all that happened here is this reporter
and everyone involved just
told everyone that they were never cool
oh yeah yeah exactly
yeah uh people are smoking weed before
the age
of 30. yeah yep
yeah people hide weed in places
yeah wait go to the video play the
facebook video
because i think she shows you that like
it's also like kids were hiding pills
and they're
stapler yeah like nobody has a [ __ ]
stapler you're an idiot you know who
else hides
you know where else they hide pills like
in their face yeah yeah they eat them
yeah they put them in their face and
they're hidden in their bodies yeah
yeah oh you can't see it
whatever it's not like uh
yeah it's fine maybe dabbling the bonus
if if need be
that is the best place i think the best
place to hide drugs honestly in your
three-hole punch or your stapler
oh you should definitely keep it in your
pencil box yeah yes with all your milky
pens yep
or in your pencil sharpener yeah oh
are those shits screwed to the wall yeah
in your elementary school class
you want to walk up go up to the side of
the wall and
or the yeah the automatic ones remember
that yeah
that you know the time you know many
times i'd hit that in a class
cody cody cody yeah what's up let's have
let's sit down
it's sharp now it's like this big yeah
like all right now teacher i broke my
pencil
i need another pencil i would hit that
slow grind
with it by hand just try to kill time
that's the best part get a test and i
don't know any of these [ __ ] answers
yeah
[Laughter]
who minted the first penny
i don't know jesus christ yeah
yeah we should get a pencil sharpener in
here
yeah just to remind people we come from
the arrow where you wrote things with
wood
yeah 90s kids baby
never forget it just a little pencil
sharpener
yeah just screwed in right there that'd
be kind of hard actually
i don't even know where you'd find one
of those things
probably like we'd probably right who
would sell it we would probably know a
manual pencil should i
need a time machine
what are you oh oh we got a pencil we've
got a pencil expert over here
jesus you really are drinking he's
drinking on the job
we probably need a time machine to go
get all this old-ass [ __ ] you're talking
about because you're so
[ __ ] old dude i'm 16.
i don't know what you're talking about
seven dollars wow we should have three
hole punch too you could hide your weed
in there
that's literally now kids are hiding
pills you got your weed in there
bro hold on oh damn it i really wanna
[Laughter]
this video is so funny it's her just
going around the stage room
talking about where kids could possibly
hide drugs luke maybe just make a
burner facebook on the side so we can
hit this at the end of the episode yeah
it's fine it's not
i don't think it's that funny but
you